you
arthur c clarke author of 2001 a space
odyssey once said two possibilities
exist either we are alone in the
universe or we are not both are equally
terrifying most media exploring the
topic of alien life in the universe
often work from the assumption that we
are not alone and that our technology is
not sufficiently advanced to detect our
distant neighbors or that they know
we're here and don't think we're worth
contacting or any number of other
explanations
while these hypotheses may turn out to
be true the other possibility that
doesn't get as much attention is that we
are in fact alone in the universe if
that were the case how would it change
our lives and our goals here on earth
for this thought experiment we're going
to assume that humanity has a way to
accurately determine that we are the
only life forms in the universe and work
from there if one day the news broke
that the universe is indeed a cold dead
place and that all life is contained
here on earth it would instantly bring
to mind two possibilities either we are
the very first life in the universe or
the very last and knowing humanity's
affinity for giant explosives we could
very easily be the first and last life
in the universe if we weren't careful
besides our new terrifying realization
that we are one planet away from a
completely sterile universe what would
change let's start with the world's
space programs if we were alone in the
universe we could scrap any missions
designed to search for extraterrestrial
life that would include numerous probes
such as those intended for the icy
landscapes of Europa and Enceladus as
well as entire branches of national
space programs like the SETI Institute
we could use the money from those
programs to redouble our efforts in
preserving the earth and its natural
resources or to fund new schools
hospitals or humanitarian organizations
of course that's probably wishful
thinking but the possibility is there if
we wanted to keep that money in the
space programs we could put it towards
research and development of ways to
ensure humanity's continued survival in
the event of disaster on earth colonies
on the moon Venus Mars or even Prototype
generational ships that could support
human colonies over several lifetimes
would be worthwhile endeavors of course
with an announcement of such magnitude
it would no doubt create polarized
groups within our global society as the
only intelligent life in the universe
would it be our responsive
to seed life on other planets by sending
probes full of bacteria and simple
organisms or are we no more than a
blight on the universe that should be
contained to earth given our history of
colonization on earth it would stand to
reason that we would at least want to
establish colonies as far away from
Earth as possible if only to ensure the
survival of our species in the event of
a gamma-ray burst or some other
Cataclysm but seeding life on other
planets will likely never visit would
probably be met with controversy so far
we've been working under the assumption
that we are the only life in the
universe at all but what if we specified
that we were the only intelligent life
how would that change the scenario well
if we assume again that humanity has a
way to determine that there is no
intelligent life in the universe then
not much will change initially however
imagine a scenario in which a probe from
Earth discovers single-celled life on
another planet let's say Europa in this
scenario we would be the billions of
years more advanced alien species
keeping an eye on new life in the
universe something that many people have
suspected extraterrestrials have been
doing to us over the history of life on
Earth but what would we do about it
to what extent would we interfere with
the growth of a new presence in the
universe many would argue that the best
course of action would be to observe
from afar and allow nature to run its
course no matter the outcome others
might want to watch but take it one step
further and intervene if the new life is
headed for catastrophe then there will
most likely be a portion of society that
thinks we should physically visit Europa
and try to guide the life-forms to
success a dangerous proposition as
humans would carry microbes with them
that could endanger the very life we're
trying to protect as one final
possibility what if we were to discover
the presence of a very primitive species
just starting to use simple tools this
would be the truest test of humanity's
disposition towards extraterrestrial
life as with the previous scenario we
could look to the zoo hypothesis for one
example of how best to handle fledgling
life-forms the zoo hypothesis suggests
that intelligent civilizations would
refrain from visiting planets with life
to allow natural evolution and
socio-cultural development it certainly
seems like the most respectful way to
handle the situation and it's not too
much of a stretch of the imagination to
think that most world leaders could
agree to contact these extraterrestrials
only once they had reached a certain
technological or societal Thresh
of course there would be others who
would want to visit them immediately and
I don't know build pyramids or something
while this may not seem like an
important topic to discuss it allows us
to explore several interesting issues
how would our space programs change if
we were the only life in the universe
would we scrap them entirely and just
focus on our existence here on earth or
would we reallocate those funds to focus
on something more like an escape plan
what a newfound certainty of uniqueness
in the universe prompt us to become a
more peaceful species or would life go
on the way it always has if we
discovered we were not completely alone
but at the top of the totem pole of
intelligence would we act like the
curators of an intergalactic Zoo would
we play the role of a benevolent god
race intervening to prevent disaster
guiding life towards civilization or
would we do the unthinkable and ensure
that no life-forms ever become advanced
enough to threaten our position as the
apex predator of the cosmos these are
only a handful of the questions this
topic can raise and who knows if we'll
ever be able to answer them only time
will tell
leave your thoughts and opinions in the
comments below hopefully we can spark
some interesting conversations and maybe
explore those ideas in future videos if
you enjoyed this video check out this
playlist of all my other space related
content or if you're really bored you
can watch all my videos by clicking here
make sure to subscribe if you haven't
already follow second thought on your
favorite social media and leave a
comment down below with your opinions on
today's thought experiment thanks for
watching and I'll see you in the next
video